Sind wir schon beim Check-in?
- Noch nicht ganz, aber auf dem Weg.
* Dynamische Musik *
Es geht links um die Ecke
und es wird etwas enger.
Keine Treppe, aber eine Rampe.
Darf ich dir das in die Hand geben?
Von mir aus müssen wir sie
heute nicht brauchen.
* Stimmengewirr *
Der Bändel
kommt über den Hinterkopf.
Ich heisse Jonas. Ich bin 26
und arbeite als Sachbearbeiter
beim Eidg. Hochschulinstitut
für Berufsbildung.
Seit meinem sechsten Lebensjahr
sehe ich nichts mehr.
Weil ich früher einmal gesehen habe,
erinnere ich mich gut an Farben.
Ich heisse Yves, bin 31
und komme aus dem Kanton Fribourg.
Von Beruf bin ich Radiomacher.
Schon seit meiner Geburt
sehe ich 2 %.
Ich sehe auch Farben und
für mich sind die Dinge auch scharf.
Verglichen mit jemandem, der
gut sieht, wäre es wohl unscharf.
Wir haben dem Fernsehen
die Sendung vorgeschlagen,
weil wir v.a.
dank zwei Dingen reisen können.
Dank der Technik und den Begegnun-
gen - Menschen, die uns helfen.
Wir wollten unbedingt zeigen,
wie wichtig es ist,
dass man einander hilft,
dass man etwas zeigt,
und dass man miteinander redet.
Durch Begegnungen
kann man Grosses entstehen lassen.
Wir werden auf unseren Reisen
oft damit konfrontiert,
warum wir als Blinde oder
Sehbehinderte überhaupt reisen.
Die Leute denken,
wir hätten nichts davon.
Dabei können wir
die Stadt auch erleben.
Über Gerüche,
über Leute, die wir kennenlernen.
Das möchten wir unbedingt
weitergeben und zeigen,
dass Reisen
auch als Sehbehinderter Spass macht.
# In every city you find
the same thing going down.
# Harlem is the capital
of every ghetto town.
Wir könnten hier
geradeaus weitergehen.
Möchtest du das?
- Ja, ja.
Dank den anderen Sinnen und den
Begegnungen habe ich oft das Gefühl,
dass wir beim Reisen
beinahe mehr sehen als Sehende.
Jetzt geht es hier rechts.
Hier kann man raufgehen.
Hier sollte es sein?
- Ich denke es.
Hier ist Ihr Zimmer.
Und das ist Ihre Karte.
Das ist der Schlitz für die Karte.
In welchen Schlitz?
- Hier.
Thank you.
We put it here.
Ah, for the ...
Das ist für den Strom.
Da, von links.
- Ah.
Stecken Sie die Karte rein!
Aha, like this.
Warten Sie kurz -
und dann öffnet sich die Türe.
Ah.
Hier ist das Badezimmer.
- Okay.
Kann ich den Rucksack hier ablegen?
- Ja, natürlich.
Thank you very much.
Geradeaus geht es zum Badezimmer
und zur Toilette.
The toilet.
Aha, ja, diese hier.
Gläser ...
... Wasser ... Löffel ...
... Früchte.
Hier ist der Kaffee.
* Scheppern *
- Ah, yes.
Wenn Sie Hilfe brauchen,
fragen Sie einfach.  - Okay.
Athen reizte mich,
weil sowohl Jonas wie auch ich,
das Weltgeschehen sehr verfolgen.
Die Nachrichten im Fernsehen
können wir nicht sehen,
darum haben wir auch nicht gesehen,
wie es in Griechenland aussieht.
Zuletzt war oft
von Griechenland die Rede,
sei es wegen der Flüchtlings-
oder der Eurokrise.
Griechenalnd spielte in letzter Zeit
eine grosse Rolle.
Um zu erleben, zu riechen
und zu hören, wie es da ist,
muss man hierherkommen.
Hier kann man Athen riechen.
An Athen reizte mich
einerseits das Kulinarische,
andererseits das Geschichtliche.
Das hier war ein bedeutender Ort
für Philosophen, Denker
und für die Demokratie.
Zudem haben mich an Athen all die
historischen Stätten interessiert.
Es riecht gut nach Essen.
- Es ist gleich Mittagszeit.
Gehen wir links?
- Ja.
* Beschwingte Banjomusik *
Nach 300 m links abbiegen.
Hier würdest du geradeaus laufen?
- Ja.
Achtung,
nicht rechts hinunterfallen!
Bin ich nicht auf der Strasse?
- Nein.
Es hat zumindest Menschen.
- Gut.
Da hat es nun keine Angaben.
Es heisst einfach ...
* Griechischer Strassenname *
Es gibt keine Angaben in Meter.
Verdammt. Was ist das?
Der Pfosten der Busstation?
Das muss das blaue Zeichen sein.
Ich habe es gespürt.
* Motorenlärm *
Unmöglich, was hier alles rumsteht!
Sorry? - Wir können via App
nachschauen, wo es ist.
Könntest du das mal machen?
Ich versuche, zu fragen.
Sorry ... sorry ...
To go to the Lykabettus....
Sorry ...
Die sind aber gesprächig.
Sorry, darf ich Sie etwas fragen?
- Ja.
Wir möchten auf den Lykabettus.
Geht es auf diese Seite
oder auf diese Seite?
In diese Richtung.
- Ah, in diese Richtung.
Vielen Dank!
- Gerne.
Wir wissen zumindest,
in welche Richtung wir gehen müssen.
Also hier, nicht da ...
So wie ich es verstanden habe,
in diese ...
In diese?
- In diese hier.
Ah, okay. Ja.
Wir haben uns schon verstanden.
* Motorenlärm *
Wollen wir über die Strasse?
Nein, wir gehen
einfach mal gerade aus. - Okay.
Rauf!
Irgendetwas lässt mich vermuten,
dass ein Pfosten kommt.
Oh!
Links.
Warum, was haben wir Schönes?
Pfosten und Bäume.
Als Fussgänger
ist man hier zweite Kategorie.
Ja, fünfte!
- (Lachend) Okay!
Bereite dich psychisch darauf vor,
dass wir in 80 m links abbiegen.
Ist gut, ja. Wir haben
auf dem Handy verschiedene Apps.
Navigations-Apps wie Google Maps,
wie sie andere auch brauchen
oder Stadtkarten.
Wir geben die Adresse oder
den Ort ein, an welchen wir wollen.
Heute haben wir das
nicht sehr genau gewusst.
Mit den griechischen Namen
ist es etwas schwierig.
Zudem wird die Schrift
auch nicht wirklich gut vorgelesen.
So bereiten wir uns vor.
Wir machen uns auf den Weg,
laufen los und lassen uns lotsen.
Evtl. habe ich die obere Bergstation
als Ziel eingegeben.
Wahrscheinlich, aber hier
kann man vielleicht links abbiegen.
* Beide reden gleichzeitig. *
Ist das die Bahn auf den Lykabettus?
Ah, great!
Man muss etwas warten. Thank you.
Jonas?
Ja, warte!
Ich bin hier noch
zwischen den Autos.
Du musst den Weg nehmen,
den ich genommen habe. - Ja.
So.
Hei, ei, ei! - Nächstes Mal
musst du besser parkieren.
Ich wollte zuerst hinten durch.
Es war auch doof,
wo wir durchgegangen sind.
Wenn wir uns
auf eine Reise vorbereiten,
recherchieren wir
in verschiedene Richtungen.
Internet, Wikipedia.
Podcasts runterladen ist auch gut,
um Dinge zu hören.
TV-Sendungen
kann man auch sehen oder hören.
Ich habe die gleiche Ansicht wie du.
Wir wollten
auf den Lykabettus-Hügel,
weil es ein bedeutender Ort ist.
Man kann über die ganze Stadt sehen.
Obwohl wir sie nicht sehen,
ist es spannend,
weil es sicher viele Touristen hat,
die die Aussicht geniessen.
Wir haben von dieser Aussicht
auch etwas.
Wir hören die Stadt von weiter oben,
z.B. mit dem Verkehr.
* Sirene *
Man nimmt die Stadt anders wahr
und es hat sich gelohnt, hinzugehen.
* Sirene *
Wollen wir ein Foto machen?
- Das könnten wir.
Wir müssten hier hinstehen.
Machen wir es selbst
oder fragen wir jemanden?
Wir machen es selbst.
- Wie machen wir das?
Wir können das schon selbst.
Also, schau. Hier ist das Geländer.
- Oh, sorry.
Bist du bereit?
- Ja.
Was muss ich jetzt ...?
Rückseitig? Nein, vorderseitig.
Also, jetzt ...
Warte, es sagt, ob die Gesichter
erkennt werden oder nicht.
Ja, genau dort. Halt es mal hin!
So?
- Nein. Achtung!
Ein Gesicht hat es gefunden.
- Das ist viel.
Dich erkennt es evtl.
nicht als Mensch.
Zwei!
Von unseren Reisen schicken wir
immer ein Foto nach Hause.
Es ist ein grosses Thema:
Reisen und Eltern.
Ich verstehe, dass es für
die Eltern nicht immer einfach ist,
uns loszulassen, reisen zu lassen.
Das Reisen wäre nicht das Problem.
Sie fanden, es wäre gut,
wenn jemand mitkommen würde,
der besser sieht als du.
Das hast du mir nie gesagt!
Ich bin enttäuscht.
Sie fragten sich,
was das überhaupt bringen würde.
Sie haben das vielleicht am Anfang
schon auch etwas infrage gestellt.
Sie konnten es nicht ...
Sie konnten es nicht verstehen
und wir mussten es ausprobieren.
Wir wollten wissen, wie es geht.
Schlussendlich
sind wir einfach Freunde.
Es geht nicht darum, jemanden
mitzunehmen, der besser sieht,
damit man so etwas
wie einen Tourguide bei sich hat.
Es geht darum, gemeinsam
etwas zu erleben und zu entdecken.
Das macht Spass, wenn man sich
mit jemandem gut versteht.
* Klicken des Blindenstocks *
Treppe!
Tritt! Ja, einer. Jetzt wieder.
Hörst du die Vögel? - Ja.
- Schön, nicht?
* Rhythmische Klavierklänge,
Stimmengewirr *
Ich stelle jeweils
Einschränkungen ein.
Man kann es gut einschränken.
Der Kaffee kommt.
Thank you! - Thank you.
- Cheers!
Thank you.
Dürfen wir Sie etwas fragen?
- Ja.
Uns interessieren die Menschen hier,
wie es ihnen geht.
Wir haben natürlich
von der Finanzkrise gehört.
Geht es jetzt besser?
Wie geht es den Menschen hier?
Leiden sie immer noch?
Na ja, wir leiden.
* Sie spricht englisch. *
Ich denke, wir haben uns zwar
ein bisschen daran gewöhnt.
Die Situation
ist nicht viel besser als früher.
Aber wir haben gelernt, dennoch
eine gute Zeit zu verbringen,
mit unseren Freunden
und der Familie.
Aber wir sind nicht reicher,
es geht uns nicht viel besser.
Es gibt viele Leute, v.a. Junge,
die keinen Job finden.
Sie müssen auswandern.
Ich habe viele Freunde, die jetzt
in London leben und arbeiten
oder in Spanien, in Schottland.
Und Sie? Sind Sie aus Athen?
Ja, ich bin hier geboren.
Und Ihr?
Wir kommen aus der Schweiz,
aus der Nähe von Bern,
der Hauptstadt der Schweiz.
Macht ihr Ferien? - Ja, wir sind
hier acht Tage in den Ferien.
Habt Ihr Spass?
Yes, it's great here.
* Dynamische Musik, Stimmengewirr *
Vorher hast du auch schon gesagt,
es sei gut.
Es brauchte viel Glauben,
um hier nach oben zu kommen.
Hier, links.
Nein!
* Dynamische Musik *
How do you know,
when it's a good moment to cross?
Ist das ein Haltehäuschen
oder ist ein Container?
Ich glaube, es ist hier.
- Das glaube ich auch.
Etwas Blaues
habe ich noch nicht gesehen.
Aber es könnte schon
ein Wartesaal sein.
Oder was ist das?
Da kommt noch eine Haltestelle.
Ah, nein, das ist ...
Vorher gab es noch eine taktile
Linie - und jetzt nicht mehr.
Genau dann,
wenn man sie brauchen könnte.
Du hast das Gefühl,
hier fährt mal ein Bus vorbei.
Ja, jetzt ist zumindest
ein Taxi vorbeigefahren.
Jetzt!
Hallo! Ist das die Busstation
vom Bus 126-550?
* Der Mann spricht griechisch *
One, two, six ... Wohin wollt ihr?
Zum Taktilen Museum.
Interamerical sagte der andere.
- Ja, genau.
... five, five, zero.
Es war dann halt so,
dass es nicht der richtige Bus war.
Wir suchten den Bus 550.
Aber er meinte,
wir sollten mitkommen.
Er hat uns in den Bus gezogen.
Wir sind sicher
keine 100 m gefahren.
Er hat uns
zur richtigen Station mitgenommen.
Guys! - Yes?
- Here.
Okay, thank you.
- Thank you.
Thank you.
Yves, hier.
- No, no. Let me.
Ich wollte sicher nicht
den Bus aufhalten.
Ich schätze die unkomplizierte Art,
die Flexibilität extrem.
Keiner motzt.
Das haben wir vielleicht
nicht verstanden.
Ja, das stimmt!
Vielleicht haben wir es
wirklich nicht verstanden.
Das sind auch jene Momente,
die mir viel Kraft geben, zu reisen.
In den Situationen, in denen es
schnell gehen muss, spürt man,
ob einem die Leute helfen
oder nicht.
Great. Thank you.
- Thank you very much.
Thank you very much. Bye!
* Klacken des Blindenstocks *
Hier kann man gut laufen.
Das gefällt mir.
(Mann) Hello! - Hello.
- Hello.
We're looking for
the Tactual Museum.
From this way, not here.
Sorry?
- Not here.
Where is the museum?
You go straight from this way.
Hier hat es wieder Leitlinien.
-  Ja.
Das ist schon mal ein gutes Zeichen,
wenn es wirklich Leitlinien sind.
Das Ziel befindet sich
auf der linken Seite.
Auf der linken Seite ist es grün.
* Klacken des Blindenstocks *
Ah, jetzt. Da könnte ... Nein.
Ist das ein Tor?
Es passt für mich zum Konzept,
dass man ein Museum für Blinde
und Sehbehinderte suchen muss.
Ich erlebe das auch oft in der
Schweiz oder an anderen Orten.
Dinge, die eigentlich speziell ...
Dienstleistungen
für Blinde und Sehbehinderte
sind vielleicht
gar nicht überall barrierenfrei.
Oder manchmal scheitert es
an ganz kleinen Dingen,
dass man nicht hinkommt.
Jonas, hier.
Left.
* Er spricht griechisch. *
30 m.
Grundsätzlich mögen wir es nicht,
wenn uns fremde Menschen anfassen.
Das ist dieser Plüschtiercheneffekt
im Sinne von ...
... oder dieser Zooeffekt, dass man
meint, alles anfassen zu können.
Das mag keiner.
Hier ist wohl auch
eine andere Kultur.
Die Leute versuchen, uns zu helfen,
auch wenn sie weder englisch
noch unsere Sprache reden.
Schlussendlich ist eine Hilfe, die
zum Ziel führt. Darum ist es super.
Da vorne ist noch ein Haus.
Warte! Vielleicht ...
Good Morning!
- Good Morning.
Wir suchen das Taktile Museum.
Ich werde Sie zum Museum führen.
Das ist Frau Rokutaki,
die Vizepräsidentin.
Freut mich.
Ich führe Sie zum Museum, okay?
- Great, thank you!
Sind Sie auch sehbehindert?
Frau Rokutaki ist blind,
sie wurde blind geboren.
So, das sind wir also.
Lassen Sie mich ein paar Dinge
über das Museum sagen.
Das Taktile Museum
wurde 1984 gegründet.
Es ist eines von vier oder fünf
Museen dieser Art weltweit.
Das Spezielle hier ist,
dass wir alles berühren können.
Great.
Sie sind sehr charakteristisch
für die kykladische Zivilisation.
Sehen Sie, sie haben nur die Nase.
Sie haben keine Augen, keine Ohren,
keinen Mund.
Keine Haare?
- Keine Haare, nichts.
Vielleicht waren sie
mit leuchtenden Farben angemalt.
Oh, Entschuldigung!
Sie gehört dem Louvre-Museum.
Sie wurde auf Milos gefunden,
einer griechischen Insel.
Sie ist nackt.
Sie hat keine Arme.
Ihr Oberkörper ist nackt.
Unten trägt sie ein Kleid.
Aha, das ist ein Kleid.
- Ja.
Sehen Sie, und hier ist sie nackt.
Sie hat unsere Hände geführt,
aber nicht zu sehr
an das Objekt gedrückt.
Sie sagte nicht,
wo wir unbedingt tasten müssten.
Wir hatten selbst die Freiheit,
etwas zu spüren oder zu entdecken.
Dieser Umgang war sehr sympathisch.
Ich habe schön gefunden,
dass wir den Körper
zu dritt anfassen konnten.
Ich finde,
dass das Vertrauen braucht.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob ich das mit jedem könnte.
Es war irgendwie normal,
dass man diese Statue spüren kann.
Für sie war es wie: "Die anderen
schauen sie ja auch an,
und es ist normal."
Diese Selbstverständlichkeit
hat mir gefallen.
Brüste oder nackte Körper sind
in dem Fall schon vor 2'000 Jahren
wichtig gewesen.
Nur Aphrodite war nackt.
Die anderen Frauen
waren nicht nackt.
Aphrodite war die einzige Göttin,
die nackt dargestellt wurde.
Wenn wir eine nackte Statue haben,
wissen wir, dass es Aphrodite ist.
Steht eine sehende Person
vor einer solchen Statue,
betrachtet sie sie als Ganzes.
Dann schaut sie die Details an,
wie dieses gemacht wurde,
wie es beim Kopf aussieht
und wie die Haare gemacht sind.
Bei uns ist es das Gegenteil.
Wir können mit der Hand
immer nur ein Detail erfassen.
Wir erfassen ein Detail nach dem
anderen - so ergibt sich ein Ganzes.
* Sie sprechen englisch. *
Oh, Musik.
Das klingt nach Steeldrums.
Oh, Gesang.
* Klassischer Gesang *
* Die Frau lacht. *
Wow! Great!
Wow!
Einfach cool.
- Wonderful.
Danke, das war
kein griechisches Lied.
Kein griechisches Lied?
- Nein, es ist meines.
Aber ich bin Griechin,
also ist es vielleicht doch
ein griechisches Lied.
This is for you.
Danke, ich werde es
in meine Hand nehmen.
Was ist das für ein Instrument?
Wollen Sie versuchen, zu spielen?
It's possible?
Spielt man das mit den Armen?
- Ja.
Ich gebe sie Ihnen in die Hand.
Hier, sehen Sie?
Und Sie hier. Sie sind hier.
- Ah.
Und hier ist das Instrument.
Das sind die Noten.
Es ist aus Eisen.
Ich glaube,
wir lassen wieder Sie spielen.
Das klingt besser.
Geiles Instrument.
- Ja, es ist cool.
Der Boden
ist nicht so stockfreundlich.
Nein.
Die Blinden hatten es früher
nicht ganz einfach.
Geht es hier rechts?
- Ob es da etwas gratis gibt?
Es scheint
ein recht grosses Haus zu sein.
Aha, oh, das ist eine Tour.
Sie sind mitten in einer Tour.
Oh, sorry.
- Das ist in Ordnung.
- Kein Problem!
Brauchen Sie Hilfe?
Are we now at the temple?
- Yes.
Wir sind auf die Akropolis gegangen,
weil sie
ein sehr bekanntes Wahrzeichen ist.
Die Lage ist speziell.
Dazu der ganze
geschichtliche Hintergrund.
Mich interessierte,
wie die Stimmung ist
und ob man etwas von den Steinen
spürt, die schon lange da sind.
Das und die Konstruktion
haben mich v.a. interessiert.
Wir biegen links ab.
Haben Sie überhaupt Zeit?
Ich gehöre zu einer Gruppe.
Hier ist eine Absperrung, aber wenn
Sie Ihre Hände etwas ausstrecken,
kommen Sie näher.
Das ist vermutlich vom Fries.
Oh, jemand hat gerufen.
- Es ist nicht erlaubt.
Sollen wir weiter?
Wir sehen den Rand des Parthenons.
Und es hat eins, zwei, drei, vier,
fünf, sechs, sieben, acht Säulen.
Und es sind immer noch Teile
der Skulpturen übrig.
Nur die ganze Mitte fehlt.
Damit wir etwas mitbekommen,
muss man einfach das beschreiben,
was man sieht - nicht mehr.
Man muss möglichst konkret
beschreiben, was da ist
und was man sieht.
Man muss aber nicht
noch eine Interpretation
und einen geschichtlichen Abriss
machen. Das braucht es nicht.
Einfach sagen, wie es ist -
das hat der Mann extrem gut gemacht.
Wir können uns den kleineren Tempel
anschauen, wenn Sie möchten.
Hier ist es ein bisschen steinig.
Passen Sie gut auf!
Kannst du dir die Grösse vorstellen?
- Schwierig.
Wir schauen nun
in Richtung Erechtheion.
Ist es derselbe Stil?
Der Stil ist ähnlich,
die Spitzen der Säulen sind anders.
Sie haben - ich bin nicht sicher,
wie man sie nennt -
korinthische Verzierungen,
glaube ich.
Zum Glück
hat der Herr auf der Akropolis
die Sachen extrem gut beschrieben.
So jemand ist Gold wert,
sonst hätten wir
viel weniger davon gehabt.
Heute fand ich es deprimierend.
Man konnte nicht einmal
zum Gebäude gehen.
Man konnte nur
die doofe Schnur spüren.
Eindrücklich war,
wie viel Platz es dort oben hat.
Ich habe es mir kleiner vorgestellt.
Den Platz dort oben abzulaufen,
das hat mich v.a. sehr beeindruckt.
Yves?
- Ja!
Da unten hört man etwas.
Da geht es vielleicht hinaus.
Es hat doch
einen schmalen Steg gegeben,
über den wir gelaufen sind.
- Ja, genau.
Dort müssten wir irgendwie ...
Wenn mal all die vielen Leute sieht,
fragt man sich schon,
warum die immer noch Kinder machen.
Dichtestress.
- Dichtestress, ja.
Um die Steine
des alten Griechenlands zu sehen,
ist die Akropolis
sicher ein Ausflug wert.
Um im Zentrum von Athen zu sein
und drum herum zu sehen -
was man uns schön beschrieben hat -
ist es sicher auch wert.
Aber idyllischere Orte
gibt es dort genügend andere.
Ich bin auch froh,
dass wir gegangen sind.
Ich habe es jetzt gesehen -
oder halt auch nicht.
Ja, nun hat es da ...
In der Nähe sollte es einen haben.
Hört man hier etwas?
Hörst du das Pfeifen?
- Ja.
Achtung, da geht es runter!
Ui, ja! Oi, oi, oi, oioi!
Da geht es irgendwo rein.
Da geht es auch irgendwo rein.
Da! Da leuchtet etwas.
Da. Hier.
Darf ich vorstellen:
Geldautomat, Jonas.
Jonas, Geldautomat.
- Herzlichen Dank.
Ich lasse dich machen.
- Vielleicht hat es Kopfhörer.
Ich glaube es nicht.
- Hat es keine? - Nein.
In der Schweiz gibt es mittlerweile
bei fast allen Bankomaten
einen Kopfhöreranschluss.
Man wird
von einer Sprachausgabe geleitet.
So kann man selbst Geld beziehen.
Hier hat es das
offensichtlich nicht gegeben
zumindest nicht
bei diesem Automaten.
Wir mussten uns helfen lassen.
Sie können den PIN eingeben.
* Piepsen *
Sie möchten Bargeld?
- Ja.
Wie viel?
- 200.
200.60.
Ah, okay.
Es gab auch schon Situationen,
als die Leute fragten,
ob sie den PIN-Code
für mich eingeben sollten.
Das war hier kein Thema.
Ich hatte den Eindruck,
dass er sich abgedreht hat,
als ich den Code eingeben habe.
Bei ihm hatte ich einfach
ein gutes Gefühl.
Er hat mich auch aufgefordert,
das Geld zu zählen.
Das hat extrem viel Vertrauen
gegeben.
Man kann fragen,
ob man die Zahlen spürt.
Einen PIN-Code lässt man
nicht von einem Fremden eintippen.
Also, 200.60 Fr.
Ob das wohl stimmt?
Ah, sind das drei 50er-Noten?
- Ja.
Thank you very much.
- Riechen Sie die Noten?
Nein, ich sehe die Zahlen.
Möchten Sie auch einmal riechen?
Schweizer Franken
riechen besser als Euros.
Ja, ganz bestimmt!
Sorry, Anafi ist in dieser Richtung?
Anafiotika.
- Anafiotika, sorry.
Ah, Anafiotika.
Gehen Sie diese Strasse runter,
links - und dann rechts.
Dort ist
ein weiterer Fussgängerstreifen.
Thank you very much.
- You're welcome.
Danke für Ihre Hilfe.
Ich muss noch rasch wegräumen.
(Lachend) Ich liebe diese Fragen!
In der Schweiz hätte ich mich
über diese Fragen sehr genervt.
Riechst du am Geld?
- Nein, er hat nicht ...
Das ist lustig,
er hat es nicht so gefragt.
Die Schweizer fragen immer,
ob wir am Geld riechen.
Wie erkennst du das Geld?
Riechst du daran?
Geld stinkt.
* Lockere Gitarrenmusik,
Stimmengewirr *
(Mann) Sweet Coconuts.
Ah, you're selling them.
Jetzt fährt er durch.
Uh, es riecht speziell.
- Das sind Erdbeeren.
Ah, ja.
Wir entscheiden auch,
wie viel Geld wir geben.
Auch Kirschen?
- No, thank you.
Lecker, aber ...
Bedien dich!
- Darf ich noch eines nehmen?
* Lockere Gitarrenmusik,
Klacksen des Blindenstocks *
Thank you,
we're waiting for the bus.
Thank you very much,
thank you very much.
Ich bin wieder da.
- Hallo. - Hallo.
Wo warst du?
- In den Ferien.
War es schön?
Die Leitlinie hörte einfach auf.
Wenn Jonas und ich auf Reisen sind,
ist es wichtig,
dass uns jemand etwas zeigt
oder von der Stadt erzählt.
Wir fragen, ob jemand Bekannte hat.
Oder wir schauen via Facebook,
im Internet, übers Couchsurfing.
Wir sind natürlich froh,
wenn das Leute machen, die sehen.
Aber sehbehinderte Menschen
sind auch wichtig.
Sie haben wieder einen
anderen Eindruck der Stadt Athen.
In 2 Min. ist sie da.
Sie ist gestresst.
- Wir hören mal.
Wenn Sehende zusammen abmachen,
dann sehen sie einander.
Man kann sagen,
dass man ein blaues T-Shirt trägt
und eine rosarote Tasche oder so.
Das geht bei uns alles nicht.
Wir sind darauf angewiesen,
dass wir uns an
einem sehr bestimmten Ort treffen.
Das kann eine Ecke, ein Abfallkübel
oder irgendetwas sein.
Der Ort muss genauer sein als
der grosse Platz des Treffpunkts.
* Stimmengewirr *
Eine Sprachnachricht.
Ja, aber sie haben ...
Hallo. Wir sind da auf dem Platz.
Okay, wir kommen zum Brunnen.
Gehen wir zum Brunnen?
- Ja, wir gehen hier rechts.
Wir kommen.
Wir folgen der Leitlinie.
(Frau) Ah, ich sehe euch.
Wie geht es euch?
- Gut, und dir?
Auch gut.
Entschuldigt die Verspätung!
Kein Problem.
Das ganze Zentrum ist gesperrt.
Keine Ahnung, was in dieser
seltsamen Stadt wieder los ist.
Aber du bist gut angekommen?
- Ja, alles okay.
Und, hattest du
ein schönes Wochenende?
Meine Grossmutter ist hier,
also in meiner Wohnung.
Ich musste v.a. bei ihr bleiben.
* Sie spricht englisch. *
* Sie reden durcheinander. *
* Dynamische Musik *
* Stimmengewirr *
Von Paraskevi haben wir mitbekommen,
wie das Leben hier für Menschen
mit einer Sehbehinderung ist.
Es gibt z.B. eine Art Versicherung.
Dadurch werden sie finanziell
etwas unterstützt.
Ich war darüber erstaunt.
Es gibt das Vorurteil, Griechenland
sei arm und müsse sparen.
Es gibt sicher kein Geld
für Menschen mit einer Behinderung.
Ich hatte dieses Bild
von Griechenland,
oder das die Gesellschaft
die Leute eher separiert.
Die verschiedenen Gruppen
in Spezialschulen schickt.
Aber anscheinend haben sie ein
recht fortgeschrittenes Verständnis.
Das hat mir gezeigt,
dass es nichts mit der
finanziellen Situation zu tun hat -
von einem Land, einer Kultur
oder einer Gesellschaft.
Es geht eher darum,
wie die Gesellschaft tickt.
Jonas und ich
verfolgen etwas die News.
Die Krise ist etwas,
wovon wir immer hören.
Ja, klar. Das berichten
die Nachrichten über Griechenland.
Aber Griechenland
ist nicht nur die Krise.
Das ist ein Klischee.
Stellt euch vor,
ich komme in die Schweiz,
und rede nur über Geld,
Schokolade, Käse oder Uhren.
Nervt es dich, dass die Menschen
v.a. darüber reden?
Ich glaube,
es ist nicht die Realität.
Es gibt über diesen Ort
so viele andere Dinge,
über die man diskutieren
und entdecken kann.
Es ist wirklich klischiertes Zeug,
worüber die Leute reden.
Aber spürt ihr die Krise?
Entschuldige,
wenn ich das noch einmal frage.
Wir haben bisher
noch nichts davon gespürt.
Aber ich glaube, die Krise ist immer
noch da - oder ist sie vorbei?
Na ja, ich bin keine Ökonomin.
Ja, ja, aber von deinem Gefühl her.
Und auch für deine Familie.
Die Gefühle sind sicher so,
dass die Leute Angst haben.
Sie sind nicht sicher, mit
wie viel Geld sie in Rente gehen
oder wie viel Steuern
sie zahlen müssen.
Oder sie haben Angst,
entlassen zu werden.
Es ist alles etwas unsicher.
Stell dir vor, Leute fragen dich
nach deiner Sehbinderung.
Du würdest sagen,
dass du versuchen würdest,
alles zu tun, was möglich ist -
und das Leben geniesst.
Das ist dasselbe.
Ist es nicht. Ich versuche,
eine Parallele zu ziehen,
damit ihr es besser versteht.
* Griechischer Gesang *
Bisher wusste ich,
dass es die Krise gibt.
Ich weiss jetzt auch,
dass die Leute die Krise spüren.
Angst macht einem, dass die intelli-
genten Leute das Land verlassen.
Also, dem Land geht Wissen verloren.
Dass es alle trifft,
ist neu für mich.
Gleichzeitig haben sie einen
Lebenswillen und Zusammenhalt,
dass sie es schaffen - das bleibt
mir von Griechenland in Erinnerung.
Es riecht schon etwas nach Meer.
- Evtl. fahren wir dem Meer entlang.
Wir sind an der Endstation.
Ihr könnt mit mir kommen.
Folgt mir!
- (Beide) Okay.
Oh, sorry!
- No worries.
Das ist schnell gegangen.
- Ja.
Sind Sie hier
auch schon im Meer gewesen?
Ich habe Angst zu schwimmen,
weil ich keinen schönen Körper habe.
Den habe ich auch nicht!
Die Menschen würden alle wegrennen.
Bei mir auch! - Nein! Sie sind jung,
Sie sind schön.
Thank you.
Nur er ist schön.
Sie auch, keine Angst!
Aber ich bin alt, alles hängt.
* Lachen *
* Sie reden
und lachen durcheinander. *
Sie sind super!
Jetzt einen kleinen Schritt
neben deinen Freund.
Thank you very much!
Es war sehr schön,
euch kennengelernt zu haben.
Gleichfalls! Eine gute Zeit.
Bye, bye.
Von Athen wird mir
die Freundlichkeit der Leute
am meisten in Erinnerung bleiben.
Die Menschen,
die einem geholfen haben.
Die Gemütlichkeit in den Strassen,
mit den Cafes
und den Strassenmusikern.
Bezeichnend für die Stadt finde ich,
dass die Menschen
so hilfsbereit sind
und sich
keine Gedanken darüber machen,
wie sie am besten helfen können.
Sie helfen einfach.
* Sanfte, griechische Sirtakimusik *
Nächste Woche entdecken wir Berlin.
Wo wohl der Fernsehturm ist?
* Schwungvolle Musik *